à quelques jours de Noël le cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa a souhaité mettre en lumière
des histoires de Russie ponctué par
l'intervention d'une compteuse Berty
soulier les enfants de Saint- l'école
ont pu découvrir le concept du cinécte
là ici c'est très particulier parce que
c'est c'est plusieurs petits
court-métrages et j'interviens à
l'intérieur des petits court-métrages et
le but du jeu voilà c'est d'introduire
de préparer les enfants au courtmétrage
comme une une mise en bouche c'est des
contus ol qui met en scène il y a une
cabane extraordinaire la cabane de de
biqut qui est entièrement construite
avec des gâteaux sucré salé des images
délicieuses et des messages de liberté
pour ce cinécte unique au mois de
décembre le reste de la programmation du
cinéma de saint-sir l'école est à
retrouver sur internet j'ai t de lui
rappeler son frère